翻訳: Koichiro YODA
校正: Hiroko Kawano
みなさんこんにちは
（観客）こんにちは
はい さっそくですが この写真
生まれたばかりの赤ちゃんの写真です
みなさん どんな気持ちになりますか
私は見たとき とっても
幸せな気持ちになりました
「人はただそこに存在するだけで
誰かを笑顔にすることができる」
そんなことを私は子どもたちに
教えてもらいました
でも 考えてみてください
ここにいるみなさん一人ひとりも
きっと０歳のときがあったと思います
この０歳でこの世に生まれ落ちて
そして広がる社会
どんな社会 どんな世界が広がっていたら
みなさん嬉しいですか？
子どもたちの命の始まりは
これからの未来の始まり
私は保育士を通して
そして今 子どもたちと携わる中で
たくさんの気付きと
たくさんの学びをもらいました
今日はそれをみなさんと
ここでシェアしたいなと思っています
［人の一生で 幼児期は 生涯にわたる
人間形成の基礎が培われる極めて重要な時期］
幼児期の重要性について
これは文部科学省のホームページから
取ってきたものです
私は子どもたちと携わる中で
本当にこの幼児期の
重要性について感じました
そして その重要性について
もっと多くの人と共有したい
もっと多くの人に知って欲しいと
思っています
さて 私は保育士をしています
保育士でこんな所に
立っているんですけれども
ちょっと変わった道で
保育士になりました
大学で福祉を学んだ後
独学で保育士の試験の
勉強をして資格を取りました
その後 保育士にはならずに
一般企業に勤めて営業をしていました
私と子どもたちとの出会いは
18歳のときです
ハンディキャップを持った
子どもたちの所に
ボランティアに行ったことから始まりました
そしてこの写真にあるように
ネパールの難民キャンプの
幼稚園に行ってみたり
そして 働きながらも
小学生たちと一緒にキャンプをする
そんなボランティアをしていました
子どもたちと一緒に
生活をしていく中で
もっともっと子どもたちに
ついて知りたいとか
この子たちの世界を知りたい
もっと人についていっぱい知りたいなと
思うようになったんです
そして 会社を辞めて
保育士になりました
保育士をしてみると
毎日いっぱい幸せでした
こんな風に子どもたちが
立つようになるんだ
ごはんを食べるようになるんだ
トイレに行けるようになるんだ
毎日 当たり前のことかもしれませんが
すごく素敵な発見を
たくさんさせてくれました
保育士をやって少し落ち着くと
ふと子どもたちの周りのことが
目に入ったんです
そんなとき ある気付きを私は得ました
「私たちのつくり出す環境ひとつで
子どもたちの人生が変わってしまう
そして その先に子どもたちが作っていく
日本の未来が変わっていく」
そんなふうに保育士の仕事の
重要性について気付いたんです
でもこれって 保育士だけだと思いますか？
そうではなくて
私は親御さんたちや
そして 社会を作っているすべての
大人たちがこういうふうに意識をしたら
何かが変わるんじゃないかなと
思っています
さて突然ですが
今日 車で来た方いらっしゃいますか？
はい
はい 何の車乗ってますか？
と ちょっと突然に聞いてみましたが
実はこんなことを５歳児の初対面の子に
言われたことがあったんです
［どの塾がえらい？何階に住んでるの？
車 何乗ってるの？］
まあ 正解 不正解は
無いと思いますが
私はこの時 言葉が出なくて
なぜかショックを受けました
その時はわからなかったんですけれども
なんでショックを受けたのか
お家に帰って考えてみました
すると気付いたことがありました
「子どもたちは社会の鏡なんじゃないか？」
そう思ったんです
「きっと大人たちやこの社会の価値基準が
子どもたちに とっても影響している」
そんなこと思ったときに
保育士として出来ること
もちろん たくさん
出来ることはありますが
この社会への影響力の大きさに
私はすごく限界を感じました
そしてさらに
まあ こんなような言葉
よく聞くかもしれませんが
［うちの子 ちっともできなくて
他の子はできるのに］
たとえば「うちの子 落ち着きが無いのよね」
なんて言う親御さんたちがいたときに
私は「好奇心旺盛で色んなことに
チャレンジして素敵な子ですね」
と言ったんですが
なかなかこう ストンと
落ちない感じがしました
「もしかしたら親御さんたちも
何かの社会のプレッシャーで
そんな風に思ってしまっている
だけなのかな？」なんて思いました
また あるとき 電車に乗っていたときに
これよりも もうちょっと厳しめの言葉で
子どもたちに話をしているような
方を見つけました
そのとき 私はすごく心が苦しくて
「子どもたちの心の声や
子どもたちが今思っていること
それはどこに行ってしまうんだろう？
誰が聞いてくれるんだろう？」
そう思ったときに
私は「保育士として
もっと子どもたちに寄り添って
何か声を聞いて それを
発信できないだろうか？」
そんなことを思いました
「親への子育てサポートができたら
もしかしたら子どもたちの
未来が変わるかもしれない
そして 日本 世界が
変わっていくんじゃないだろうか？」
そんなふうに思ったんです
そして 保育園を辞めて
外に飛び出すことにしました
とはいっても「どこの保育園ですか？」
と まあ当たり前に聞かれます
でも 私はそうではなくて
保育園のその先の社会を
フィールドにした保育士として
「こども未来プロデューサー」という
新しい仕事を作ろうと決めました
子どもの未来を保育士の専門性を持って
もっと広く社会を変えていけないだろうか
そんなことを思って外に飛び出たんです
そして こう転々と色んな
コミュニティを歩いているうちに
１人の保育士に出会いました
彼女もまた 保育士として
「子どもたちの未来のことを真剣に考えて
そして社会を変えていきたい」
そんな強い想いを持った
１人の保育士でした
私たちはすぐに意気投合して
「何か子どもたちのためにできないか？」
保育士を集めたり
いろんな大人たちと子どもたちの
未来について話すような会をしました
そして今では保育士２人で起業して
会社をやっています
私たちは保育士の専門性をフルに
生かして社会をデザインしていく
様々な企業さんや様々な方と
手を取り合いながら
子どもたちにとって本当に
いいモノ そしてコト ヒト
そんなものをデザイン
していけないだろうか
そんな事を日々考えて
仕事をしています
そして 私たちが
大事にしている子どもは
保育園だけの子どもではなく
この社会にいる子どもたち
そして 日本を越えて
世界 地球にいる子どもたち
すべて大事な命です
そんな子どもたちのために
私たちは保育士として
できることを発信しています
そんな社会デザインの１つの事例を
少しご紹介させてください
今 言ったように
「保育士の専門性を少しだけおすそ分けを
できる場所を作れないかな」と思いました
それは保育園を超えて
色んな方に私たちが見てきた沢山の
子どもたちの良さやいろんなケース
そしてたくさんのご家族を
見てきましたので
それをシェアできないか
そんなふうに思ったんです
そこで大事にしたことが
いくつかあります
まず 子どもたちは
特に乳幼児期の子どもたちは
１人で外に歩いて行くことができないので
親御さんたちが行きたいと思うような
環境を設定しなければ
ならないなと思いました
そして 選んだ場所が
初めはカフェでやりました
大人も子どもも
お互いに幸せな気分だったり
少しリラックスできたり
そんな環境を作るために
カフェという場所を選びました
そして ここで大事に
したことがあります
それは 大人も子どもも両方ともが
学びがあったり
楽しみがあったり
何かリラックスできたり
素敵な気持ちになるような
環境の設定をするということです
例えば大人の人には
私たちが育児相談をしたりとか
何か美味しいものを食べてもらったり
ちょっとだけ子どもと離れて
少し自分だけの時間を作ってもらったり
そんなことをするだけで
親御さんたちはすっと心が楽になります
子どもたちの隣に笑顔でいられるような
環境というところを
サポートするお手伝いを
しようと思いました
そして 子どもたちの方はというと
こんな感じです
まあ日常にある物で
設計をしているんですが
そこにも訳があります
子どもたちは何もなくても遊びます
みなさん思い出してみると
色んな場所で子どもがいますが
そこにあるもので遊べます
まあそれに近い環境を作るために
リサイクル素材だったりとか
手に入りやすいもので
あえて構成をしています
ここで子どもたちが
自分が表現したいことを
自分が好きな素材を知って
自分らしく表現して
何か作り出していく
もしくは 何かで遊んでいく
そんな環境を作ることを
大事にしています
そして お母さんたちにも
お父さんたちにも
遊びのヒントを
持って帰ってもらえるように
お家でも用意できるような
簡単な素材にしました
今お話しした設定が揃うとですね
こんな風に遊びが展開していきます
これ初対面の子どもたちです
自分たちで遊びを作り出して
繋がり合って楽しむ
そんなことを周りにいる
親御さんたちは見て
何かを感じて帰っていく
そんな場所作りをしました
子どもたちが楽しんでいると
まあこれがSNSの効果も
あったんでしょう
３回目にして60家族が来てしまって
カフェに入らなくなりました
そこで私は考えました
どうしたらこれを続けて
いけるんだろうと
そんなとき またひらめいたんです
「子どもたちが住む世界は
この社会すべてだから
使っちゃいけない場所なんか無いし
きっと行っちゃいけない場所も無いし
色んな場所でこれを
やったらどうだろうか」
そんなアイデアを１つ（ずつ）
走りながらですね
企画しながら
そこにいる子どもたち
そこにいる親御さんたちの声
そして保育士たちの色んな声を聞いて
形にしていくことにしたんです
たとえば 公園ではこんな形で
なかなかお家で
こんなことできないと思います
それを思いっきり
やらせてあげられるように
保育士たちの仲間に
協力してもらったりとか
ゴミ袋をこう着てもらって
自由にできるように
そんなふうな環境を作っています
でも先ほどの素材やルールや
環境の設定など
基本的なものは一緒にしました
他にも こんなふうに
商店街で販売体験をしたり
あとはライブハウスで
思いっきり楽器で遊べるような
環境を作りました
ここでですね まあ親御さんたちが
周りにいるんですけれども
やっぱり子どもたちは
親御さんたちの自分の好きなことや
連れて行ってくれる場所
その中で自分の世界を
選択するというような
まだまだちっちゃい子たちなので
自分たちでこう外に出て
選択肢を広げていくことは
できないかもしれません
ということで家族丸ごと
自分たちではできない
体験だったりとか
なかなか外にひと家族で
行けないような企画っていうのを
保育士たちと一緒に
やっていくことにしたんです
すべてのイベントでですね
一緒のルールがあります
それを今からご紹介しますが
たった４つだけしかありません
それが行われるとですね
こんなふうに子どもたちが
自然に笑顔になります
そうしていくと
親御さんたちは何回も来ます
「うちの子 ここに来ると
すごく笑顔が素敵で
もっとこういう機会を
作ってあげたい」とか
「お家でこれをするには
どうしたらいいんだろう？」とか
親御さんたちも 今度は自発的に
自分たちで考え始めるんです
そんなルールをご紹介します
１つ目
「大人だから 子どもだからと
決めつけないこと」
大人もできないことも
できることもあります
同じように 子どももできることも
できないこともあります
人間として同じです
なので完璧な人もいません
だからこそ「ここはフラットで
誰もが自分らしくいられる」
ということを設定しています
そして２つ目
「頭ごなしに否定をしないこと」
今 いろんな所で
禁止事項が増えていますが
私たちがやるときには
否定語を使わないように
してもらっています
もちろん危険な時には止めますが
走って欲しくない所を
走っていた時に
「歩いてね」と言うこともできるんです
私たちが発する言葉に
注意を傾けてもらって
どんな言葉を子どもたちにかけるか
そこに意識をちょっとだけ
置いてもらうようなことを
２つ目においています
そして３つ目
「まず 共感すること」
たぶん みなさんも
経験あると思うんですが
子どもたちって大人がちょっと
理解できないような物をこう作って
自信満々で見せて来たりしませんか？
そんなときに「何それ？」と言うのか
それとも「ああ 何か丸めて作ったんだね」
と共感してあげることで
子どもたちはその先に色んな
説明をしてくれたり
色んな世界を発信してくれるんじゃ
ないでしょうか
そして最後 ４つ目
「価値観を押し付けないこと」
たとえば チューリップを
黒で描こうとします
みなさん止めますか？
もしかしたらその子は
チューリップの影を
先に描いたかもしれません
そういうふうにして
ちょっと大人が見守っていくと
また子どもたちの世界が広がる
可能性が増えていきます
たった４つだけです
子どもの隣で 私たち大人が
どんなふうにいるか
そしてどんな環境を選んで
どんなものを置いて
どんな言葉をかけるか
それで子どもたちは持っている力を
どんどん外に出していくことができます
それが子どもたちにとって
一番重要なんじゃないでしょうか
さて この間実施したイベントを
１つご紹介させてください
これはSkypeでフィリピンの
ストリートチルドレンの子どもたちと
交流をしたイベントです
日本側の３歳ぐらいの男の子でした
紙皿に洗濯バサミをつけて
こうライオンを作りました
「これ見て ライオンだよ」と
向こうの子に見せたんです
そしたら「本物見たことある？」
というふうに向こうの子は言いました
日本の子たちは
「あるよ 動物園に行けばいるじゃん」
というふうに言いました
すると向こうの子たちは
「僕たちお金がないから
ライオン見たことないんだよ」と
にこやかに明るく教えてくれました
私はそのとき思ったんです
子どもたちは環境を設定していくだけで
遊びの先にこのように学びを得ていく
それこそが学びの本質
なんじゃないかなと思いました
もし私たちが貧困のことや
フィリピンのこと
ストリートチルドレンのことを
伝えようと思っても
きっとライオンの話は
出てこないと思います
このときにはもしかしたら子どもたちは
理解してないかもしれませんが
きっといつの日か
その同じ言葉を聞いたりとか
何かのタイミングで
この日のことを１人でも思い出して
くれたらいいなと思います
私たち大人の役割とは
そういうふうに色んな選択肢を
子どもたちに与えること
じゃないかなと思うんです
そしてこの写真
みなさん何を感じますか？
子どもたちの視線どこにありますか？
これ 「遊び」と言いますか？
私たちはこれも遊びだと思っています
子どもたちはカラーセロファン１つで
色んな光の世界や
このようにコミュニケーションを
取りながら
人のことを知ったり
いろんなことを観察しています
遊びの可能性というのを
すごく感じているんですけれども
やっぱり何かを作り出すことだけが
遊びではなくて
子どもたちからしたら
「何かをつかむこと
何かを触ること 何かを壊すこと」
すべて遊びなのかもしれません
そういうふうに大人たちが考えたら
もっと子どもたちの
遊び場 遊び方が
増えていくんじゃないかなと
思っています
「遊びは 人と人とをつなぎ
人と世界をつなぐ」
子どもたちはこの世界に生まれ落ち
自分たちで遊びながら
いろんな世界の扉を開いて
いくんじゃないかなと思っています
さて そろそろ最後になりますが
もう１つ 私が１歳児クラスの担任を
していたときのことをお話しします
１歳児クラスの15人の子どもたちは
まだハイハイの子もいました
そしてまだ なかなかうまくおしゃべりが
できない子たちの集まりでした
でも そこで起こったことに
私はすごく心が動きました
子どもたちは毎日思いっきり笑って
思いっきり泣いて
思いっきり人とケンカして
言葉が無くたって
人と人とが繋がっていきます
そんな子どもたちの光景を見たとき
「多様性社会って もしかしたら
こういうことを言うんじゃないかな？」と
本質の部分を私は何か
感じることができました
子どもたちはそういう力を
もともと持っています
その力を大人たちが
どんな環境を作るかで
そのまま大きく育っていくか
それともそうでなくなってしまうか
決まってしまうのかもしれません
もし その力をそのまま
伸ばすことができたら
きっと 今この地球にある色んな問題
差別や貧困や戦争や
そんな問題がなくなるんじゃないか？
そういうことを
彼らは教えてくれました
その力を守っていくために
もしかしたら 先程言った
４つのルール
これは子どもたちだけではなくて
友達 夫婦関係 そして家族
もしかしたら企業の中でも
そうかもしれませんが
「大人だから 子どもだからと
決めつけないこと」
「頭ごなしに否定をしないこと」
「まず共感すること」
「価値観を押し付けないこと」
ぜひみなさん １つでも
出来れば今日からやってみてください
さて 最後になりますが
今日もどこかで新しい命が
たくさん生まれています
みなさんはどんな社会を子どもたちに
プレゼントしたいなと思いますか？
そして その社会はきっと
私たちの幸せにも
繋がってくるんじゃないかなと思います
今日は 私のこのアイデアを
シェアすることで
誰かが誰かのために何かできたり
少しでも気付きを持って
一歩前に進んでもらえたら
きっと未来はもっと良くなるん
じゃないかなと思っています
ご静聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）